[Music]
i'm cory burnette and i run the business
called first aid for leather by sandal
man in toronto canada i'm going to be
taking you through a restoration process
of a 70 year old horsehide leather
jacket
i believe the jacket was worth about a
hundred dollars 70 years ago and it's
probably worth about fifteen hundred
dollars today it would probably be about
a fifteen hundred dollar restoration
this is a jacket that was made out of
horsehide which in the past um was
something that was quite common
nowadays most
leather jackets of its type are
reproduction made out of cowhide which
is not as strong as horse height it's
basically broken down on every aspect
the knit cuffs and waistband the
leathers completely deteriorated over
time as you can see the fading and
drying out
the collar which is made from
sheepskin has started to bald and lose
hair
the first thing we have to do is take
everything apart part of the treatment
process is just washing down the surface
of the leather with a ph balance soap
which is non-invasive
it helps to
keep the original colors without
stripping any of the pigment from the
leather
i'm removing the knit cuff and waistband
from the jacket
by using a seam ripper to take it off
from the edge of where it was sewn
in the case of the knit cuffs it goes
around in a circle so you basically just
pick an area start with that and then
just go around till you get to the end
if you're going with the zipper we would
go and start at the top and then move
down to the bottom we do this along all
the edges where the material is attached
to the leather then the lining had to be
disassembled
[Music]
once the lining is disassembled then we
have to break it into its parts
[Music]
once we've disassembled the entire
jacket we have to then re-pattern by
using the original design because we
have to make sure that everything fits
back together in exactly the same way as
it was made in the first place the
original collar is made out of sheepskin
it is starting to show signs of what i
call balding after so many years of use
you'll find that the hair starts to
disengage from the base material
the first thing that we do is we
disassemble it from the original collar
and then we flatten it out to allow us
to get an accurate
reading on the measurements and then
that gets cut out so that way we have
all of the proper seam allowances to
allow for the stitch to go on
i've chosen to modernize this design
rather than trying to restore it back to
its original it gives more contrast to
the brown leather by using the black
trim fabric on the zipper is black the
knit in black as well as the internal
lining is made from a quilted lining
made out of black so everything has a
consistency amongst the jacket
once i take the internal lining out of
the jacket we break it into its various
parts everything is pressed with an iron
to make sure that everything lies flat
and then we make sure that we have
enough lining material when we're
cutting it
because if we don't do this properly
then it'll end up being short
when i'm rebuilding a lining for a
jacket it has no pockets it's just a
flat piece of material we then have to
create the pocket in this case we
created a leather trim pocket we have to
cut the leather pieces that are going to
be incorporated into the pocket and it
has to be cut and sewn in such a way
that when it's completed it is a
finished pocket the cuff is made from a
combination of cotton and polyester and
elastic
so it's woven together
so that it has a nice soft feel and at
the same time it has a little bit of
elasticity so that it holds on your
wrist and on your waistband and keeps
the air out when we're making
measurements we want to make sure that
we we make marks on it that are not
invasive to the material that can easily
be wiped off i like using a chalkboard
chalk it easily comes off
that allows us to get accurate
patterning and then wipe it off later so
it doesn't leave a mark
[Music]
once we cut the materials we then have
to reassemble everything back to the
original design
the toughest part about reconstructing a
jacket like this
is just making sure that everything fits
together exactly as it had begun we do
this one step at a time with each
individual aspect of the jacket the
cuffs have to be turned inside out and
sewn and then folded over so that it
creates the double layer all of the
linings have to be sewn back together we
make notches at various points of the
lining so that we know as we're sewing
that we're sewing it to the right point
so that where the shoulder starts and
the side begins that each of those
points are met in the right way
the waistband have to be put in before
the lining is attached because the
lining will then cover up the knit the
knit gets sandwiched between the leather
and the lining so that way if you were
to turn it inside out you'd see a nice
clean finish
[Music]
we do a conditioning treatment with the
liquid oil for a week and then at the
end of that process we then move on to
the thicker oils so we're getting a two
week treatment with two different oils
with only a couple of days break in
between
after 70 years of use all the initial
essential oils that were part of the
leather have all evaporated what i do
when i'm treating the leather is i'm
putting back some of those essential
oils you'll notice also the flexibility
of the leather increases because once
the oils get introduced to the leather
everything starts to soften up all of
the fibers inside the leather everything
becomes healthier darker more supple
[Music]
[Music]
you